imaginez une capsule pour remonter le
temps 10 ans en arrière précisément et
bien cette capsule existe symbolique
certes mais tellement précieuse disant
donc après avoir encapsulé leur dessin
d'enfants les anciens élèves de l'école
Clocheville à Tours les ont redécouverts
avec le regard tendre du jeune adulte
voyez ce reportage
mars 2013 les élèves de CM1 CM2
choisissent des objets et des écrits
qu'ils vont glisser dans une grande
boîte une capsule temporelle
une vache avec des ailes c'est c'était
un jouet de quand j'étais bébé une
Barbie les enfants ont 10 ans maintenant
et dans 10 ans ce sont des jeunes
adultes et pour endurer toute la
différence qu'il y a entre l'orage et la
capsule temporelle c'est cette immense
coffre remplie de dizaines de boîtes 10
ans ce sont écoulés les mêmes enfants
devenus jeunes adultes et leur maîtresse
d'école désormais à la retraite font le
même parcours cette fois pour ouvrir la
capsule c'est un projet qui est récit
quand on fait un projet on se dit
qu'est-ce que va être l'évaluation la
dévaluation est réussie puisque tout le
monde en fait tout le monde voulait
venir mais alors que met-on dans une
boîte lorsque l'on a neuf ou 10 ans
de dessin de mon futur métier je voulais
être radiologue à l'époque
je vais faire professeur des écoles
[Rires]
tout ce que j'avais mis mais je savais
pas que j'étais attaché à ces choses là
quoi il y avait un livre monsieur
bagarreur c'était ton cas
oh non je me garerai pas trop
j'avais écrit dans ma boîte mon secret
qui était mon copain préféré Benjamin
si là mon secret c'était que je voulais
habiter dans le sud de la France et mon
copain préféré à l'époque était
également Marius
en 2013 lorsque les enfants enferment
leur souvenir ont écouté Stromae à
tue-tête c'était l'adoption du mariage
pour tous et la mort de Nelson Mandela
dix ans plus tard les années CM1 CM2 ne
sont pas si loin ça fait du bien de
retourner dans le passé un peu et ouais
je suis content d'être là quand même
aujourd'hui ça fait plaisir j'ai fait
j'ai fait 1000 et une bêtises entre
guillemets avec mes copains et tout et
ça ça nous lit au final et parce que
l'amitié et les souvenirs sont précieux
ils ont décidé de ne pas attendre si
longtemps rendez-vous dans 5 ans
[Musique]